the Maneater that terrorized Primo a
tiger should never be underestimated a
young desperate Hunter named Vladimir
marov was hunting in the forest when he
stumbled across the mutilated corpse of
a wild boar an enormous tiger exploded
from the forest after a horrified Markov
in a panic he threw the ball to the
ground desperately opened fire onto the
tiger and escaped with his life into the
forest the tiger was easily able to
identify the scent of who shot it the
tiger had set its mind on killing marov
slowly savoring the hunt and
anticipating the kill at this moment he
could have packed up his things and left
but instead he decided to confront the
animal